Jojen paste is a Game of Thrones fan
Theory claiming that bran eats Jojen
which sounds crazy but may actually be
true so let's have a look in season four
of Game of Thrones and book 5 of A Song
of Ice and Fire
bran stark travels north with Jojen
Meera Hodor and in the books cold hands
a mysterious walking corpse they go to
the home of the three-eyed crow or
Bloodraven a dreamer wizard and
greenseer connected to the weirwoods and
the children of the forest and the magic
of the old gods
the point of all this apparently is for
bloodraven to teach bran to use the
magic power of the old gods the powers
of a green sea R so in dance we get a
sort of a training montage kind of like
Luke Skywalker's training in Star Wars
amongst darkness and twisted tree roots
and old but powerful mentor trains a
young hero to unlock his mystical powers
bran learns to see into the past through
the eyes of weirwood trees and to better
skin change and to the minds of animals
as part of this training bloodraven and
the children of the forest give bran a
bowl of white paste apparently made out
of weirwood seeds it's thick and heavy
with dark red veins running through it
that look remarkably like blood
apparently the purpose of this paste is
to help awaken bronze gifts and wet him
to the trees so bran eats it then has a
vision through the eyes of a weirwood
tree afterwards he finds Jojen and Meera
curiously absent he then has more
visions and the chapter ends and that's
the last we've seen of burn so the judge
and post theory claims that the weirwood
paste that bran eats actually contains
the blood or body of children so what's
the evidence firstly the tone of this
whole chapter is really really dark and
ominous its imagery includes dead men
dark clouds blood stew murders of crows
chambers of bones are talking corpse and
whispers in the dark it's like a
Halloween haunted house in here there's
particular emphasis on flesh and blood
and knives the line the moon was a
crescent thin and sharp as a blade of a
knife appears four times in this chapter
as the phases of the Moon are used to
track the passage of time so the tone
and imagery of this chapter really set
the scene for something bad to happen
maybe something in
blowing knives and flesh and blood and
it strongly implied that something bad
is going to happen to Jojen of course in
the show Jojen is already dead he's
stabbed then mercy killed then blown up
by a child of the forest because
apparently that's what you do but in the
books
Jojen survives the whites and while
brown trains he mopes around blood
Ravens cave growing ever more sullen and
solitary food and rest improve his
physical health after their journey but
he seems sadder now sullen with a weary
haunted look about the eyes at one point
he implies that he has a reason to be
afraid and this seems to be related to
his green side his prophetic dreams of
the future Meera says Jojen will not
even try and fight his fate he says the
green dreams do not lie
Jojen has hinted that he's foreseen his
own death in his dreams so what seems to
be going on here is that Jojen is upset
because he knows his death is coming why
might Jojen have to die
surgeons job is to bring bran to
bloodraven so Bloodraven can teach bran
to use the magic of the old gods but
magic in A Song of Ice and Fire is not
some Harry Potter swish and flick
[ __ ] magic in this world is messy
and ugly and it often has a price when
Daenerys uses magic to try to keep Drogo
alive the price is the life of a horse
and of danny's on porn child
Melisandre needs King's blood and the
burning of innocence to work her magic
euron greyjoy makes blood sacrifices to
make his ship sail faster and there are
many other examples from many different
cultures across the world of Ice and
Fire of the need for human sacrifice or
blood sacrifice in magic so it makes a
lot of sense that awakening brans magic
would also require human sacrifice
especially when we're talking about the
magic of the old gods
we're told repeatedly that Northman used
to make human sacrifices to the
weirwoods and thus cargo sea apparently
still do further brown's lost vision in
this chapter is of a woman slashing a
captives throat before a weirwood tree
and as his life flows out of him in a
red tide bran can taste of the blood so
in the same chapter where bran eats this
suspiciously bloody we would paste to
awaken his magic we're reminded of the
connection
between the magic of the old gods and
the weirwoods and human sacrifice
further with human sacrifice and blood
magic one person's blood can be more
powerful than another's for example
Melisandre specifically needs Kings
blood for her most powerful magic this
might explain why jochen's blood is
needed rather than mirrors or hotels
because while Georgian isn't a fully
fledged green seer like Bloodraven he
does have green dreams prophetic dreams
and special mas green eyes that mark his
gift
Jojen has the power of the old gods in
his blood
so it makes sense that his sacrifice
specifically has the power to awaken
bronze magic another thing that's going
on here if Jojen paste is real is
cannibalism and cannibalism is a
recurring theme in the North Stannis is
starving soldiers eat their own fallen
Wyman Manderly bakes phrase into pies
Vera Mir eats human flesh while walked
into his wolf and cannibalism especially
unknowing cannibalism is a recurring
theme specifically in bronze chapters
when bran is at the Nightfort he recalls
the tale of the rat cook who cooked a
handle prince in a pie and served him to
his father then was cursed delivers a
rat eating his own young in the cave of
the three-eyed crow bran and KO ate
suspicious meat that it might be
squirrel or rat or maybe something else
and when Brown is traveling north cold
hands feeds him the flesh of some nights
Watchmen and tells him that it's pork
also like Faramir bran eats human flesh
while walked into his wolf
so bran has already eaten human meat
snacking on some Jojen would be just one
more example of cannibalism in his
chapters further on the journey north
Brown and Coe heed cold hands elk which
Brown feels guilty about because he
considers the elk a friend so bran has
not only already been eating human flesh
but he's already been eating his friends
so the pieces are starting to come
together this chapter is really dark and
ominous it strongly hinted that
something bad will happen to Jojen it
makes sense that Brown's magical
awakening would require blood sacrifice
and cannibalism is a theme of Browns
chapters it looks like maybe blood Raven
and the children of the forest secretly
kill dojin and put his blood in the
weirwood paste that they feed to bran in
to awaken brands magic but does that fit
with what we know of bloodraven
bloodraven doesn't exactly seem like a
good guy just look at him he's a hundred
and twenty five year old half corpse and
half tree with weirwood roots sneaking
in and out of his withered flesh he's
less a man than some ghastly statue made
of twisted wood old bone and rotted wool
he lives in a cave full of creepy forest
elf children and the bones of thousands
dead his home is literally littered with
human skulls and look at the [ __ ] he
says never fear the darkness bran
darkness will make you strong to return
to the Star Wars comparison bloodraven
is much less like Yoda than he's like
Vader or the Emperor his dark seductive
manipulative and deceptive Brown thought
bloodraven would be a wise old wizard
who could fix his legs he never signed
up to become a psychic tree and what
about dojin Mira and Hodor what's going
to happen to them they can hardly return
to the wall with winter setting in
maybe Bloodraven has good reasons for
all this leaf says he works for us for
you for the realms of men but even if
that's true bloodraven really doesn't
seem to have bran George and Mira and
hurdles best interests at heart
he risks their lives bringing them to
his cave he never explains what it is
that he wants and his turning bran into
something that he never wanted to become
if sacrificing Jojen was necessary for
blood raven's goals it's easy to believe
that he'd do it finally this theory
could fit well with Browns character arc
bran starts the story as a boy who
dreams of being a heroic Knight like in
the fairy tales just like Sansa dreams
of becoming a noble lady both of these
characters get what they wish for Sansa
quartz a prince in the royal castle and
brand journeys into danger in search of
a magical power but Sansa soon realizes
that the world she dreamed of is
actually pretty terrible Joffrey's a
monster and so sees a quote vile
scheming evil [ __ ] bran is starting to
make a similar realization cold hands is
a monster and the mystical three-eyed
crow is actually a creepy half corpse
tree man maybe part of this
disillusionment for bran will be the
horrific discovery that he ate his
friend and there are a bunch of
interesting ways that could go
maybe after finding out bran would try
to get away from bloodraven which might
be difficult for someone who can't walk
or maybe he'll embrace the darkness
anyway Brown has done some pretty messed
up stuff lately like walking into Hodor
all the time even though it clearly
makes Hodor distressed however bad this
bloodraven stuff is it empowers Brown at
a time when he's frustrated by his
helplessness maybe he'd be too immersed
in his green seer power to notice or
care about the death of children another
interesting factor here is that Brown
has a crush on Mirror how would mirror
react to jochen's death and how would
Brown react to mirror and what will
happen to poor Hodor there are lots of
different ways this could work but the
point is that Jojen paced could fit into
Brown's story in some really interesting
ways possibly as part of a turn towards
darkness so is there any strong direct
evidence that bran eats Jojen no there's
no strong evidence against it either but
here's what we do know in an extremely
dark and ominous chapter it's strongly
implied that Jojen knows his death is
coming bran eats a suspiciously bloody
weirwood paste and afterwards Jojen and
Meera seem to be gone the paste is meant
to awaken brands magic power and we know
blood sacrifice is often needed to work
magic especially the magic of the old
gods and the way it was cannibalism is a
recurring theme in branch chapters with
Brown having already eaten the flesh of
humans and a friend's blood Raven is a
creepy nasty dude who seems willing to
put his goals above the safety of others
and Brown's story seems to be heading
towards a confrontation with the
darkness so there's nothing concrete
here but the pieces do seem to fit
it seems very plausible likely even that
bran unknowingly eats Jojen in blood
Ravens we would paste thanks for
watching and thanks to all supporters on
patreon including xandria Leonard mr.
fever sa Cameron waistline yer dog
Michael Apelles the a Dalek we Stephie o
the seventh Jason Rattray and Madeline
cockerel thanks to your support old
shift X is now going full-time which
means there'll be many more videos
starting in the coming
akes so again thank you and please
comment to let me know what you'd like
to say from old shift X next Cheers
you